hello everyone I just came back from the
dentist so I apologize in advance if I
will not be able to pronounce all of the
words that being said welcome to round
three of the 2018 Norway championship we
have an extremely crazy game between
Shakira mamedyarov and Sergei kurakin
now the funny thing about this game is
that a circuit car can actually prepared
the line plays in this game for both
white and black so he would play this
position with both white and black
pieces and he already played a game in
this line against the dealer and a but
in that game he had he had the white
pieces and England was black and that
was again from the Mishima Memorial but
a really crazy game in its I believe
it's the first game that finished from
round 3 so you know I just came back
from the dentist I thought yeah let's
show this game so let's see it we don't
have any photos but we don't have this
one it's from the live feed so you know
we can enjoy that one before we check
out the game so I will give it a couple
of seconds for you to enjoy it
ok very nice now let's see this game so
mama Kiev is white and he opens would be
for e5 Knight to f3 knight c6 Bishop to
c4 the Italian game and Bishop to c5 of
course an excellent opportunity to go
for the Evans gambit but we will never
see that in in top level chess and until
we do and I'm sure we will see it one
day so c3 the main line of the joke Oh
piano Knight to f6 we have D 3 D 6 and
we have castles H 6 in his game against
the Engler and Eliran went for castles
here and using the experience from that
game park an improved and he goes for h6
rook to e1 we have castles h3 and a5
Knight B to d2 Bishop to e6 and Bishop
to b5 now avoiding the trade of bishops
and here comes just for us so you can
see to what extent the preparation in
these games goes but you already seen
that in in the previous game you've seen
in Causton versus Kerrigan
here we have a queen bee ate a very nice
idea that actually prepares Queen a7
which temple that's eyeing the f2 pawn
then pushing a4 and then transferring
the Queen all the way to a5 so nice to
f1 we have Queen to a7
now the f2 pawn is under attack rook to
e2 defending and here we have a 4 as
planned
9th to g3 Queen to a5 and now Bishop
captures on c6 pawn captures and now
Kerrigan doesn't win the bishop pair but
it's it's a pretty close position before
he can use the power of the bishop pair
he has to make the position in his favor
so nice to h4 we have look after he ate
and now rook to e1 preparing preparing
making room for the Queen so the Queen
can come into the game nice to f5 was
also a very nice idea so rook to e1 King
to h7 and now comes Queen to f3 bringing
the Queen into the game d5 pawn captures
Bishop captures and Queen to a5 check
this was very interesting kurakin shows
that Queen to a5 check doesn't really do
anything and what do you do here well
you do have a couple of options you can
go King h8 you can go King g8 and you
can push g6
obviously if you push g6 your knight on
f6 is hanging if you push play King to
h8 then you get Bishop captures on h6
and if you capture then Queen captures
night with check it's very interesting
what happens if King to g8 is played
if King to g8 then once again Bishop
captures on h6 and now you have to
defend with Bishop to f8 but White will
always be better here of course if you
capture then after Queen captures on f6
to stop the threat that is nice to f5
and Queen to g7 checkmate you do have to
you do have to pick away the Queen and
after rook to e6 Queen to f5 and there's
a really no good way to prevent
c4 and black will lose a piece here so
after Queen to a5 check black indeed
plays g6 and again we have a very
interesting position of course white
cannot grab
the night immediately if you play Queen
captures then you get Bishop to e7
Bishop to e7 attacking the Queen and the
night behind the Queen and after Queen
captures on e5 and now you capture the
night and now White has the opportunity
of playing Queen captures on e8 and
after row captures Queen captures and
it's a very nice position where where
it's actually the position is equal but
to go for something like this yeah I
don't know if it's an equal position you
always prefer the side that has the
Queen so definitely not going for this
so after this g6 move first we have
Knight captures on g6 as the knight will
come under attack if the knight on f6 is
captured pawn captures and only now
Queen captures on f6 and we have an
interesting position once again so what
do you do here well obviously if you if
you allow white to make a couple of
moves attack h6 here or there are a lot
of threats black will lose this game so
it's interesting what happens if Bishop
to e7 giving away the Queen you get the
same idea here Queen captures on 8th on
e5 and after Bishop to d6 white can once
again give up the Queen for 2 rooks and
again you get a position where white
will be better but you know you do
prefer the side that that has the Queen
so after this Queen captures on f6 rook
to f8 was played by my kurakin because
he found a spectacular defensive idea as
he is the Minister of Defense Queen to
h4 was played and now the threat of
course is Queen captures on h6 so take a
look at this position and try to find a
nice defensive idea for black a rather
the only defensive idea for black and I
do want you to pause the video here and
you know you black also has some threats
but it's a very dangerous position so
what do you do here for those of you who
found it congratulations you are an
excellent defender as well as Sergey
Kerrigan and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
let's first let's first check out a
couple of ideas well of course if you
play something like
Bishop captures an f2 immediately simply
King moves and there are no ways to
continue here even Bishop captures white
will simply ignore it and after king -
h2 still there is there is nothing to do
here Queen captures and h6 is still
coming so what are some other ideas well
they're really they're really they're
really aren't all that mean and all that
many h5 white can simply capture it so
the move kurakin played and i hope you
found it was actually g5 and this is
often the case in chess the the simplest
move is often the strongest move so how
do you proceed here well of course the
pawn must be captured if you play
something like Queen Queen to g4 then of
course what captures on f2 will be
deadly white white it doesn't really
have a good move against against Ruka
for discovered check so the only move
that you thought was of course Bishop to
g5 of course now Queen captures on h6 is
still a threat and now it's very
interesting what do you do here well if
you play Bishop captures on f2 now you
still get a king - h1 and after Bishop
captures an g3 Queen captures on h6 King
moves now Queen g6 check King to h8 and
now simply rookie to move moving the
rook away from danger
and white black is still up a piece but
the Queen and a5 and luke and I are
completely out of the game and black has
no good ways of of stopping whites
attack he can try to bring the Queen
into the game but now comes Queen Queen
h5 check King moves Queen to g4 now the
thread is of course Bishop to e3
I discovered check that wins the Queen
rope to f7 now Bishop to e3 a discovered
check rock blocks and now Queen captures
King characters and Bishop captures on
c5 and all of a sudden white is up two
points and white has a rook for a bishop
so also up the exchange in a completed
winning position but after this Bishop
to g5 kurakin found a move that will
will save him the game he found rook
captures on f2
and it's very interesting can can you
really allow this well it seems you can
so Queen captures and King to g8 and
here you you can't allow any any
discovery rook to f6 you lose the Queen
it's all over so I will have Queen to g6
check King to h8 Queen to h6 check King
to g8 Queen to g6 checking to h8 Queen
to h6 check King to g8 and after Queen
to g6 check and King to h8 Queen to h6
check or maybe it was you know one
repetition lesson but in the end the
players agree to a draw rather you know
a draw was agreed upon as as there was a
three-fold repetition but it's very
interesting what happens after this
Queen to g6 move if the King moves to f8
it's also a very nice position for you
to check out there are plenty of good
moves here for white but you know one
line is very forcing so feel free to
pause the video here and find the best
line for white so as usual I will give
it a couple of seconds for the review
found it once again you know you are an
excellent attacker and for those who
just want to enjoy the show
Bishop to h6 of course once again the
move you thought about first is the
strongest move King g7 now comes rock
captures and if I would check King d7
Queen g4 would check King moves and a
brush up to g5 and the King has nowhere
to go
although all the lines are blocked so
you do have to give up something rook f6
we have d 4 as now rook f6 came with a
discovered check but after d4 and Bishop
here simply rook captures King captures
and Bishop captures on f6 and now black
is simply getting checkmate that rook f1
check in d7 check check check check and
Queen to e7 this will be checkmate there
are a lot of lines that are good for
white but this one seems to be seems to
be the best and of course it's not
important if you found all the moves
just the starting idea you know you
would find all the other moves during
the game so yeah but after Queen to g6
check looking to King here and Queen to
h6 it
the draw but still a very nice draw and
although it was only 30 moves a really
really a fighting game and I think it's
very interesting that it's actually
Kerrigan who prepared this variation
with white and black but in the end it
was only a mama DRF who who could win
this game and who could get a better
position so a very strong player soccer
mom Y ro and of course a member of the
2800 club I will be very interesting how
the tournament continues so far both of
them three draws and Carson still in the
lead he he won the only game so far in
this tournament but as the other games
from round 3 are still being played and
he has a pretty nice position against
Levin our union will probably be
checking out that game as well so yeah I
would like to thank Ariane it Krasny key
Mario's da Millennials and Danny
McCullough for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
probably would woodturner get a video
from the norway championship but I'm
really busy busy in the mornings so I
didn't have time to continue the the two
remaining rounds from the 2013
candidates but I will return to that no
worries
so once again thank you all and I will
see you soon